everybody was mad about Merrill at the
premiere a big little lies but only our
lauren zima got miss Streep and the
whole lady game mean at the Merrill I
know I have to like take a breath Latif
breath every time I charge are just
hitting narrow unset' is the dream of
your life everybody was talking about
honestly how nervous they were to meet
you they calling you the Queen the
legend when I forget my lines they go oh
[Music]
this cast is so fun did you get to
unwind with these amazing ladies have a
glass of wine after a hard day and have
some fun on set ah glass out glass
why in Monterey gotta get the wine
essential it is the wine that binds us
Merrill's character coming to town
there's just a lot of tension in
Monterey how are you I can't complain
actually I can my son is dead she brings
her talent she brings legitimacy from
Merrill mania to all the best
big little looks free stunned and Elie
Saab posing with her 19 year old
look-alike daughter are we wearing San
the wrong lucky me
zoe kravitz rocked the same designer and
shailene woodley was a real standout in
this Dior dress with a body suit
underneath you gato dazzled in a sparkly
Michael Kors blazer but for Kidman the
night wasn't about fashion but family
Nicole Instagram this sweet picture
embracing her two youngest daughters and
we love this
[Music]
Nicole and her hubby Keith Urban
performed a duet before he joined her on
the red carpet no surprise Nicole nailed
it she performed the Elton John hit and
Moulin Rouge
I have the most extraordinary partner in
life I will always say that about him I
have a wonderful husband
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]